[Music]
in this day and age everyone is thinking
of new ways to save money we certainly
are and that is why we've made a list of
methods to make your money go further
stay tuned until the end when we'll be
showing you a simple but effective thing
to help you save money if this is your
first time visiting the things that it'd
be great if you could give this video a
like and hit the subscribe button today
we are showing you 20 money-saving hacks
you need to know drying without
electricity if you do your own washing
then there's a good chance you use an
electric tumble dryer to get them dry
but did you know that in an average
household the dryer accounts for as much
as 10% of the electric bill that's as
much as 200 dollars a year if you live
in the United States so we think there's
a better way to get your clothes dry you
should see about drying them on a
clothesline this will help protect the
environment save you money on your
electric bill and keep your clothes in a
good condition for longer by the way did
you know that April 19th is national
hanging-out day you do now change your
font it's a good idea to avoid printing
documents out if you can because that is
a good way to save money on paper
however sometimes you can't avoid doing
so we all know that printer cartridges
can be pretty expensive so what if there
was a way to keep printing but reduce
the amount of ink you're using well
there is one particularly cool way that
you might not have thought about that's
changing your font there are some funds
such as Ryman eco font that are
specially designed to save you money on
ink
alternatively you can use a smaller less
flashy font
studies show that Garland and Courier
use half the ink of big fonts like
impact Airport water fountains if you
are lucky enough to go traveling then
you'll know that airports can be pretty
expensive places to visit once you're
past security there's nowhere to go so
the places can put their prices up and
it's often the little but essential
things that add up and make your trip
pricier than it really should be that's
why it's a good idea to take a small
empty bottle with you and then make use
of water fountains a lot of airports
have them and they can save you a bit of
money that you can spend when you get to
your destination instead also some cafes
and restaurants will let you refill your
bottle for free but be sure to ask
download your old CDs if you
music lover the chances are that you
have bought CDs at some point however if
you're old enough to remember the time
before mp3s and online music streaming
then you may have bought CDs which have
either gotten lost or damaged but if you
want to listen to them digitally there's
no need to go through the trouble and
expense of buying them again at least if
you bought them from Amazon that's
because the company's auto rip service
applies to music purchase since 1999
meaning you can find the CDs and
download the music in mp3 format the
other really cool thing about this is
that it also applies to vinyl carry cash
spend less one of the biggest
technological changes in the recent
years has been the growth of debit and
credit cards it's not really easy to pay
for things because you don't need to
worry about getting cash out you can
just use your card and there you go
however one of the downsides is that
it's a bit hard to keep track of how
much money you have been spending but
there is a solution research has found
that people who pay with cash are more
likely to be cautious when it comes to
buying things which saves them money so
go to the ATM get your cash and avoid
using a card for impulse purchases keep
your calendars the next one is a real
money-saving hack for people who like to
plan a long time in advance but it is
pretty cool do you buy calendars so you
can keep track of things a lot of people
do but they are an expense that can add
up it might seem like a calendar is
something that you can avoid buying
because different dates fall on
different days every year however there
is a way around that and that's by
remembering that every few years the old
days and dates match up again it sounds
like it might be a bit tricky to keep
track of but luckily there's a website
to help you win can I reuse this
calendar com grow food not lawns a big
part of anyone's weekly budget is
getting the food shopping in it's
something that has to be done all the
time but it's also something that can
end up costing a fair bit of money
everyone needs to eat so there's no
getting around it or is there if you
have a garden you can save yourself
money by growing some of your own
fruit and vegetables if you do that you
will be amazed at the money you can save
it takes time but we think that it's
totally worth the wait if you want more
information then you should search for
grow food not lawns online make your own
household cleaner if you've got a home
then you know just how important it is
to keep your house tidy clean and
smelling nice it's pretty much an
essential thing to do however it's also
true that getting good cleaning products
can be a bit expensive but don't worry
because you can make a really good
cleaner using a range of items that you
probably have in your home already what
you need to do is get a glass container
that's heat-resistant fill it with
citrus peels and add boiling water and
white vinegar if you leave it for a week
you'll get something that'll end up
making your home nice and clean and save
you money to abandon your online
shopping baskets have you ever gone
online to do some shopping and then got
distracted and ended up not checking out
your online basket it's not an uncommon
thing to happen but did you know that
websites keep track of that you probably
did but there's a really good thing that
can happen to you if you do that some
online retailers notice when people have
abandoned their online shopping and
because they want people to buy from
them they offer those people discounts
pretty cool right it doesn't happen with
every side of course but there are some
big names to do it so if you're looking
for money off from the likes of ASOS H&M
and ebay then give it a go ask for
discounts what do you think of when you
hear about haggling we think that you
might imagine doing a deal at some kind
of street market but believe it or not
it can be done in regular stores
you'd be surprised but a lot of major
retailers are open to doing deals quite
often if something is available online
for less than it is in a shop then you
can get that money off this often works
well for electronic retailers who will
certainly be more open to offering you a
deal if you ask nicely
of course it varies from store to store
and you need to have a bit of confidence
and don't worry if they say no but give
it a go know when to buy your car for a
lot of people the single most expensive
thing they own is their car it's a vital
thing to own in this day
age but there's going to be a
significant outlay so if you know what
it is that you're looking for then you
might want to see about how you can get
money off your motor car dealers are
usually trying to reach sales targets as
a rule of thumb they are more likely to
worry about hitting their quotas at the
end of the month but a lot of the time
it's easier to negotiate a discount at
the end of the month
then at the start fill your cistern if
you pay the utility bills for your home
you will know that something that often
ends up costing a lot more than you
think is water obviously we need to
drink water and we need to keep
ourselves and our homes clean but it
would be a good thing if we could all
save a bit so there's one classic way to
do it and that's to fill up your toilet
tank or sister end with a jug full of
sand that way you'll have the same
amount of pressure when you flush but
you won't use water that you don't need
to use some people say you should use a
brick but that can end up clogged in
your plumbing take the downshift
challenge when you do your grocery
shopping what do you buy do you go for
the stores own brand or do you go for
the bigger more established and price
your goods when you buy one particular
brand do you go basic regular or premium
there's one way that you can save money
and that's by taking what's called the
downshift challenge this is where you go
one lower than what you'd usually get
for instance there's a choice between
premium and regular and you usually buy
the premium then you should try the
regular likewise if you usually buy
regular you should try basic it sounds a
bit odd but is something that really
works plan meals one of the worst things
that you can do is to go food shopping
when you're hungry there's something
about having an appetite that makes you
more likely to buy food that you don't
need that might be too expensive and
that you won't get round to eating the
best way to avoid doing that is to plan
your meals in advance if you organize
what you're going to eat it makes things
a lot easier to keep track of and best
of all you won't end up buying food that
isn't going to
even on a whim what's great is that with
modern technology there are apps that
can help you do this so you can plan
ahead and save use your phone's GPS if
you own a car the chances are that you
will at some point have to go somewhere
that you don't know how to get to back
in the old days you'd need to write down
a list of directions before you went out
so you could follow them but then global
positioning services were developed and
then pretty much every motorist went out
and got a satellite navigation system
however with new technology you don't
have to splash out an expensive
navigation device if you have a smart
phone the chances are that you've got a
Maps application with that and while
that might not have as many features as
a sat-nav it'll certainly get you where
you want to go users
everyone likes a bargain and one of the
best ways is to use a money off Bowsher
once you know where to look for them
these things are everywhere
traditionally they appear in magazines
and newspapers but now you're just as
likely to find them in electronic form
online if you do a search you can find
them for pretty much any website that
sells things so that can really help you
save some money however there is one
thing that is definitely worth us
pointing out and that is that you have
to be careful to both make sure your
voucher hasn't expired and that it's for
something that you'd be buying anyway a
new kind of speaker perhaps the biggest
game-changer in the way we consume music
has been the smart phone not only did
the mp3 revolution means that we didn't
have to have a music player and physical
copies of music with a smartphone meant
we didn't need a computer although it's
good to listen to music on headphones
sometimes it's nice to share the music
with people however specialist
smartphone speakers cost money if you
want to save then you should check this
one out you need your phone a paper roll
holder a knife and some scissors make an
incision in the roll then cut out a hole
for your phone if you put the phone in
the hole it'll amplify the sound buy
stolen goods legally something we need
to say right away buying things that you
know to be stolen is both morally wrong
and illegal it can get you into serious
trouble with the law however when
someone gets convicted of a crime where
they made money and obtains goods
thanks to their illegal actions the
police often confiscate their goods but
what happens then well with some police
forces they auction these things off
these can
two people getting some serious bargains
and quite often the money goes to
charity two sometimes they're on
websites sometimes it's on eBay and
sometimes it's in a physical option so
if you see something you want then check
it out
use dollar stores one of the smartest
retail ideas to have really kicked off
in the last couple of decades has been
the growth of the dollar store as the
name suggests they are stores where
everything costs a dollar of course if
you live in a country which doesn't have
dollars you might will have your local
equivalents such as the pound store or a
euro store but anyway whatever currency
you use they are great and they are
especially useful for the smaller things
to be fair a lot of the time you'll be
getting branded products at a discount
at least that's what we've seen when
we've been in them so it can be a very
good deal don't waste food one of the
biggest things that we waste is food
it's quite easy to cook too much and
then throw the rest away when we've
eaten enough and sometimes we brought
too much food so we end up throwing
things away when they become moldy and
stale however just because it's easy
that doesn't mean that you should do it
one of the best ways to avoid that is to
get some airtight containers that your
food can go into if something's in a jar
time keep it in your cupboard until
you've opened it and then transfer
anything you don't eat to a container
but we wondered what's your favorite
money-saving tips tell us in the
comments and that's all for our 20
money-saving hacks you need to know if
he likes it then why not check out ten
insane life hacks you should dare to try
thanks for watching and don't forget to
subscribe
[Music]